[MUSIC PLAYING]
BENJAMIN SCHROM: Hello.
Welcome to our session.
We really appreciate you
choosing to spend the next 40
minutes here with us
given the number of things
that are going on at I/O.
It's really busy time.
My name is Benjamin
Schrom, and I'm
joined here by Jennifer
Miller and Brittany Mennuti.
And we're all from
the team at Google
working on immersive computing.
We want to talk to you today
about using immersive computing
for teaching and learning in a
few really important and really
different contexts.
But first I want
to make sure we're
all on the same page about what
we mean by immersive computing.
In the simplest terms
we mean VR and AR.
VR, that can take you anywhere,
like to the Taj Mahal,
to another place and time, down
to the atomic level, wherever.
And AR that can bring you
anything, a dinosaur, a jet
engine, da Vinci's 15th century
design for a helicopter,
or just information about
the world around you.
But the reason we say,
and will continue to say,
immersive computing
is that at Google, we
look at these technologies
as occupying different areas
on a shared spectrum.
Increasingly, all
points on the spectrum
are beginning to blur
together more and more.
So the plan today is to spend
a few minutes walking through
specifically why and how we
see this technology being
used for teaching and learning.
And again, we really mean
teaching and learning
in the broadest sense.
So I'll share some updates
about Google Expeditions.
Jen will talk to us
about our efforts
to bring this technology
to higher education.
And then finally, Brit will
walk us through Tour Creator.
So why are we here for
the third I/O in a row
talking about this?
Like, what's the big idea here?
For us, the really powerful idea
is that we have an opportunity,
with almost any technology
on this immersive computing
spectrum, to help turn the
abstract representations
of things that form so
much of our education,
of our work, of just sort of
how we perceive the world,
into more concrete
experiences that
activate our minds
and our bodies
and allow us to
learn by experience,
sort of a continuation of how
we all learned things as kids.
And for the set of
things we're going
to talk about
today, what we want
to enable is this
technology makes
those concrete experiences much
more regular things, much more
accessible, and as
effective as possible.
And this is really important
because we all need it,
like our kids will need
it, future generations
will need it.
So two years ago at I/O, I
posed this classic math problem
to the audience.
And I wanted to
check back and see
if anyone got the answer
in these last two years.
I've actually now learned
this is a classic problem.
It's actually called the
Age of the Captain problem.
Many, many studies
have posed this
or similar sorts of questions to
primary and secondary students.
Anyone have an answer on
how old the captain is?
It turns out a majority
of your average primary
and secondary
school math students
will produce a numerical answer
to this question, 66 out of 97
in the most recent
study I could find.
The researchers in
this study actually
termed this phenomena "the
suspension of sense-making",
which now that I know it, is
actually a really useful phrase
in all kinds of contexts.
But it's kind of a doomsday
scenario for when learning
becomes too abstracted.
And I think it
really illustrates
for us both the challenge
and the opportunity
that we have before us.
The opportunity is that instead
of asking a student why they
should spend time studying
why ancient Rome is important,
or asking them to appreciate
these amazing artifacts
of human history with just some
little pictures in a textbook
or a video on a
little screen, you
can let them explore it in VR,
like they were there in Rome.
You can give them this
bite-sized field trip moment
that engages their
mind, their body,
gives them the agency
to look around.
Or you can let them evaluate
a statue of a powerful woman
in history, like Cleopatra,
like it was standing right
in front of them.
Another way to think
about this is a theory
that's popular among cognitive
scientists who study learning,
the so-called
cognitive load theory.
People heard of this?
It says that our
ability to learn,
you can think about
it like it's a funnel.
And basically it's the
total mental energy
that we have to learn
something is what's left over
after you've subtracted
the inherent difficulty
of the thing that you're
trying to understand to learn,
plus the effort
required to understand
how that concept is presented.
So what you're left with
is the mental energy
you have to learn.
So if fractions had an
inherent difficulty of x,
there's this other
difficulty of y
that's just trying
to understand how
fractions are presented to
you or how it's taught to you.
And we can't do much about
the inherent difficulty
of these concepts.
The world is a really
complicated place.
But we can do something about
that orange part of the funnel,
about how information
is actually
presented to people when
they're trying to learn it.
But when you look at
so many of the places
that learning actually happens,
like classrooms and lecture
halls, they really aren't set up
to lessen that cognitive load.
They're basically only
set up to explain things
with words or 2D drawings.
And then you realize
that not a lot's
changed in hundreds
of years, like this
is how we were teaching
people in the 15th century.
And for us, it makes
scenes of students
using AR in their class
seem almost overdue.
So let's start with talking
about Google Expeditions.
We launched Expeditions
at I/O three years ago,
and it's been incredible
to watch it grow.
And now tens and tens
of thousands of schools
are using it every single day.
But at its core,
Expeditions really
hasn't changed much from
how we first conceived it.
It's a tool that
allows a teacher--
or we call them a guide--
to take groups of co-located
students on virtual field trips
or show them virtual things.
And since we
announced it in 2015,
we've continued to see it grow.
And we've continued
to add features
to make it even more powerful
and even more accessible.
And as of today, we're
really excited to share
that over three million students
and teachers have participated
in one of our Pioneer
Programs, and that Expeditions
has been installed on
over six million devices.
And we're so encouraged by
the continued enthusiasm
and excitement we've seen from
teachers and students who've
been using it for
multiple years now.
In addition to the steady
stream of qualitative feedback
we've received,
we've also started
to get some real quantitative
data back as well.
And it's still early
days for this stuff,
but in a recent study, we
worked with researchers at SRI,
we found that students that
used Expeditions VR as part
of a specific science lesson
outperformed those students who
used that same lesson but
with traditional 2D media,
like pictures and video.
And they did so by a
statistically significant
number.
So I wanted to share
a few of the things
that we've learned along
the way and some things
that we're doing
to make Expeditions
even better and even
more accessible.
So first, we've learned
that while cardboard
might be an awesome material out
of which to build a universally
available VR headset, it
might not be the best material
out of which to build
a VR kit for schools
to use Expeditions with.
This was the first Expeditions
kit box we made back in 2015,
and we were so excited
when it arrived.
We thought it was the
coolest thing ever.
We had cardboard headsets,
we had a cardboard kit.
Well, there was our
Expeditions cardboard box
after about two
hours in a classroom.
Big surprise, right?
Classrooms are harsh
environments for technology.
So we knew we had to bring
on some partners to help us.
And so today we have
kits like this in school
across the world.
Who here wishes they
had a VR cart like that
in their class
instead of a TV cart?
Yeah, me too.
We now have over 10
different partners
offering kits in over a
dozen different countries.
We've also learned
that if we want
to reach the most
number of learners
possible with technology
like VR and AR,
we need to remove as many
technological prerequisites as
possible.
So we started by allowing
Expeditions to work offline
so that even in schools
like this one in Ghana,
they could travel
the world with VR.
Or in this school hundreds
of miles up the Amazon River,
they could go outside and
compare their environment
to ones all the way
across the world.
So last year we removed
another prerequisite and made
Expeditions work for users
who didn't find themselves
in a classroom or in a group.
And we've actually seen
lots and lots of teachers
use the solo mode
in their classes
to let their students explore
the world on their own.
And we'll soon be updating
the Expeditions home screen
to make self-guided tours much
easier to discover and jump
into, while still
making it really simple
and straightforward
to use in class.
We've also been making some
really amazing new content,
like the set of Expeditions
we made with the Earth VR
team that brings the
incredible experience of seeing
Google Earth in VR to
Cardboard and Daydream.
And we used the technology the
Daydream team recently open
sourced and made
available called Seurat.
Seurat allows you to take a
highly complicated 3D mesh,
like this scene from Google
Earth of New York City,
and simplifies it
down to a scene that,
within a limited headbox, can
be viewed on mobile VR devices.
It's really, really
powerful stuff.
And it's especially
really powerful stuff
on the recently announced
Lenovo Mirage solo device.
These sorts of
Expeditions really,
really come alive with
the six degrees of freedom
you get with the Mirage.
And we've continued to add
just more and more engaging
and interesting content to
our library of Expeditions.
We now have over 800
different Expeditions
spinning history,
STEM subjects, art.
There's really
something for everyone,
every teacher, every
student every curious adult.
We will also continue to
partner with the real experts
in the field of educational
publishing, like HMH.
We now have a series
of Expeditions
that supplement their textbooks
and, as we were discussing
at the outset, make all that
important information contained
within the textbook become
more accessible and concrete
with the set of
accompanying VR content.
But most importantly,
we've learned
that when you take
students to amazing places,
like underwater
among coral reefs,
they really want to investigate
the things they see there,
like coral or sharks.
They want to get up close.
They want to take
the opportunity
to look at this guy
right in the eye,
to look at those
rows of sharp teeth.
So Expeditions AR is
our answer for how
you bring that shark into the
classroom such that everyone
remains dry and intact.
We gave you a preview of
Exhibitions AR last year
at I/O. And we
spent the last year
taking our beta
application around
to schools all over the world.
Over one million
students and teachers
participated in our beta.
They gave us their thoughts.
They helped us refine
it and improve it.
We wanted to take this
chance to thank them
for such thoughtful
feedback, for seeing
through some of the
early rough edges,
and for just inspiring us to
build it each and every day.
Go ahead and check out hashtag
#GoogleExpeditions on Twitter
if you wanted to see some
amazing scenes of people
using Expeditions AR.
The feedback we've received
has been super encouraging,
like this ninth grade teacher
from Boise, Idaho, who
saw her classroom come alive.
We love that last
part in the quote
most of all, that
students have become both
the teacher and the learner.
And this is really
the holy grail,
giving amazing
teachers like Karen
the technological instruments
to make moments like this
happen in her classroom.
So Exhibitions AR will be
shipping as a major update
to our already launched app.
AR will live alongside
VR in the same binary.
And we'll be shipping it
at the end of the month
with over 100 different
AR Expeditions composed
of objects that span the same
breadth that our VR tours do.
History, art, chemistry,
biology, natural history,
math, the list goes on.
And I want to give you a quick
run through of the features
we'll be launching with.
First, as we do in VR, one
of the most powerful tools
that we can give a
guide is the ability
to draw the group's
attention to specific areas
or points of interest.
But we needed to design
a new way to point out
parts of the object.
So we built a
spotlight feature that
lets a teacher shine a light
on part of the object such
that all the
students can see it.
The teacher can move
that spotlight around,
they can make it a
pinpoint or a floodlight.
It looks really, really cool.
We also learned that the bigger
the elephant, the better.
But the spaces people have
available to them are all
different sizes,
so you need to be
able to quickly resize it
and let that propagate to all
the connected devices.
And while we don't use
markers for tracking,
we've learned that physical
marker images can actually
be a great way of establishing
a common reference
point for large groups that
are viewing the same object.
So with Expeditions,
you can put down up
to eight different
markers around your space,
and the objects you
choose to show your group
will display right
on top of them.
This helps to ensure you
don't have 30 kids crowded
around the same object.
And just like we have
a solo mode in VR,
we also have a solo mode in AR.
So if you aren't guiding a
group, you don't need a marker.
You can just tap on any plane
that your device detects
to place that object
and have a look,
and you get all the explanatory
information in a little card
to read about.
Like, who doesn't want the
Mars Rover on their table?
So as I said before,
Expeditions AR
will be shipping at the end
of the month as an update
to our current application.
There's no need to
install anything new.
To experience AR, you'll
need an ARCore enabled
device like the Pixel.
But for schools that
love their VR kits--
and there are more and
more and more of them--
Best Buy Education
will be offering
a best of both
worlds VR and ARKit
built with the Asus ZenFone AR.
And this device does
high quality AR and VR
just beautifully.
We're also really
excited to announce
that the recently debuted
Acer Chrometab 10,
the world's first Chrome
OS tablet designed
from the ground up
for use in schools,
will be supporting both
ARCore and Expeditions AR.
And finally, for those schools
with ARKit-enabled iPads,
we'll also be bringing
these same updates
to the Expeditions iOS app.
And just like Cloud
Anchors that you
may have heard of in
an earlier session,
it will work
cross-platform so you
can use an Android device to
guide an iOS device or vice
versa.
So that's it for Expeditions.
A beautiful new UI,
a powerful set of AR
features, and a bunch of cool
AR content to go with it.
It's basically a
museum in your pocket.
OK.
So we're going to
change gears here.
We're excited, too.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Beyond K-12 learning, we're also
seeing lots and lots of signs
that this technology can
create engaging experiences
for university students.
And to talk to you about that,
I'd like to introduce Jen.
JENNIFER HOLLAND: Thanks, Ben.
Beyond the
curriculum, we quickly
learned that there was even
broader learning opportunities
with VR.
In the same way
that learning can
be an abstraction for many
students, going to college,
pursuing different
careers is an abstraction
for students around the world.
These students don't have
access to the mentors
and the professionals
in their life
that have experience
going to college
or have experience
pursuing different careers.
So for the past few
years, we've been
creating hundreds of college
and career Expeditions
to enable students to be
able to visualize what it's
like taking that step
across that graduation stage
and accepting that diploma,
or taking that first step
and applying for that dream job.
And along those same lines,
many educational programs
have not been
traditionally represented
by women and minorities.
And it can be difficult
for these students
to imagine what it's like to
participate in these programs.
But we know VR can
help with this.
One school, the New York
Tandon School of Engineering,
has taken us to a
completely other level.
They were looking to improve
the impact and the diversity
of their incoming
freshman class.
So they created a VR app.
And they enlisted the help
of students and faculty
and built a bunch of
different experiences
showcasing the different
projects and programs happening
on their campus.
And the admissions team
created these custom
branded cardboards, sent out a
letter to all admitted students
with instructions on how to
actually download the VR app.
And apart from doing this
to separate themselves
from other schools, the
immersive experience,
mainly highlighting the work
of female students and faculty
and narrated by a
woman, has helped
to increase the female
acceptance rate of students
by over 10% in just two years.
Yeah, come on.
We can cheer for that.
That's so impressive.
When the admissions office
surveyed that incoming class,
many cited the VR app
as one of the reasons
why they chose the New York
Tandon School of Engineering
because they could visualize
what their four years were
going to be like
on campus and get
to experience working with
different faculty and students.
And beyond using the
VR for admissions,
we're seeing professors
like Adam Blumenthal
from Brown University
capture historical sites
using Google's Jump camera,
and then marking those videos
and 360 photos up
using in Tilt Brush
and using tools
like Blocks and Poly
to vividly recreate important
historical moments in history
like the Gaspee Affair,
which happened off
the coast of Rhode Island.
It was a dramatic
event in the lead-up
to the American Revolution.
Students can now walk
through this virtual tour
and experience a
preserved part of history.
But not all faculty
are like Adam
and know how to build
immersive content.
So to help faculty and
students get started,
we created a free VR
video course for anyone
to be able to take.
And we'll also be launching
an AR course this summer.
We've also provided schools
with sample projects
to help them get inspired for
how they can build experiences
using VR and AR.
And we've also established
a hardware loan program
so that schools can apply and
get the necessary hardware
to help them get started
on their first projects.
Since launching the VR video
course and the hardware loan
program this past fall, we've
received really positive
feedback from
students, like Michael
here, who have actually
taken the course.
And one thing that
we're seeing is
that more and more
students like Michael
are going online to
pursue an education.
In fact, 32% of students took
an online course just last year.
This is a really
powerful notion--
that your access to
a great education
is no longer dependent on your
geographic proximity to one
or dependent on having all
day, in-person classes.
Imagine if you wanted to
pursue a career in, let's say,
nursing, and you had to take
a set of prerequisite courses
like biology.
And your closest university
is 200 miles away.
You might decide it's
worth it, and so you go
and you look up the courses
that are being offered.
And you realize
that biology class
is offered Mondays, Wednesdays,
and Fridays from 1:00
to 4:00 PM.
But you have a full time job.
You're probably not likely
to register for that class.
And you might also consider a
different career opportunity
that allows you
more flexibility.
Almost all degree
granting institutions
offer courses online.
But many popular courses
and degrees, like biology,
require in-person
activities like labs.
Because of this, schools either
don't offer those courses,
ask students to pay
really high course fees,
or ask remote students
to drive hours to attend
these in-person activities.
It turns out this doesn't scale.
But we know we
have the technology
to enable these experiences.
And that's why
we're excited today
to announce that in partnership
with Labster, a science
education company in Denmark,
we have removed the physical lab
requirements to complete
an online biology
degree using virtual reality.
[APPLAUSE]
Schools will now be able to
truly offer an online biology
degree.
The 30 labs can fully
simulate real-world outcomes
using advanced simulations
and mathematical equations all
built on the Daydream platform.
These labs are
economically efficient,
as the cost of the VR headset
and the content for the labs
is still cheaper than
the years of lab fees.
And it provides scale to a
growing number of students
that are pursuing
courses online who
previously were left out because
of geographic constraints.
Students are also able
to have unlimited lab
time, which is something that
many schools can't offer today.
And as one student
put it, I no longer
have to worry about
having a bad TA.
Students are also able to
engage on a molecular level
within these labs, which
is impossible today.
And we're really
excited to announce
that the first university
that will be offering these VR
labs to their students
is Arizona State
University this fall.
[APPLAUSE]
And what's also exciting
is that these labs
map to AP and IB courses
for K-12 schools,
so schools that want to
supplement their existing
curriculum with these VR labs
can go ahead and do that.
And for those schools that
can't afford creating a whole VR
laboratory in their school,
they can offer these VR labs
as a replacement.
Labster also connects the
lab progress with major LMS
systems, including
Google Classroom, which
will be integrated this fall.
And it allows teachers
to actually track
the progress of students
throughout these VR labs.
Labster has been able to help
reduce all of the laboratory
costs for schools by
virtualizing hundreds
of machines and equipment.
I'm not sure what this
HPLC or the PCR is,
but I'm pretty sure
I could do something
fun with that fermenter.
We think this is the
beginning of something big.
What better way to use
the power of the VR
than to offer a
powerful education?
And with that, I'll hand it
off to my colleague Brit, who
is going to talk
a little bit more
about how VR is being used
in the classroom and beyond.
[APPLAUSE]
BRITTANY MENNUTI:
Thanks so much, Jen.
Programs like Labster
got us thinking,
how could we scale
this kind of immersive
learning to more people?
And how can we make it easier
to create this kind of content?
Now we all know that most of
us don't have the expertise
to recreate a $1 million
laboratory in VR.
But we also know that many
of us have things to teach
and stories to tell.
And since the earliest
days of Expeditions,
both teachers and students
have asked for the ability
to create their own.
So we started to
think about what
it would be like to make it
easier to create VR content.
That's why, in January,
we launched a beta
for students and teachers to
make their own Expeditions.
In partnership with Ricoh,
we outfitted students
in schools all over the globe
with Ricoh Theta 360 cameras
and kits of Chromebooks,
cardboards, phones, tripods,
everything they needed to
create their own Expeditions.
We encourage them to
use the theme love
where you live so
they could showcase
their communities to other
schools participating
in the program.
Let's take a look at
the experience of one
of these schools in
Lancaster, Pennsylvania
with this quick video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I was born and raised
here in Lancaster.
- It is definitely a
big farming community.
- You see family farms
everywhere you go.
- And I think it's really cool
that we have this opportunity
to share our way of life.
- How we're going to do
this is using a new tool
called Tour Creator.
- It's an interactive,
easy to use
tool that allows our students
to create rich, 360 degree
experiences.
- You will see the photos that
the ag department and the art
department have supplied.
- Add a title and
description, click on that,
and then it'll bring
up the street view.
We can plug that
into the actual tour.
- It will definitely inspire
me to show more of Lancaster.
And hopefully it'll inspire
people to do the same.
- And it's wonderful that we can
have our students interacting
with all of these
other students' stories
across the globe.
- This is Chicago's Little
Village neighborhood.
- That's very close
living quarters,
very different from around here.
- We were just looking
at the one from Bali.
Their classes are
basically outside.
- I really thought
that that was neat.
- Everybody's different on
the way they like living.
- And every place
has a unique story.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
BRITTANY MENNUTI: Now
Penn Manor high school
is just one of
hundreds of schools
around the globe that have
participated in this program.
For example, Spry Links
Community High School
in Chicago made an amazing tour
of Chicago's Little Village,
showcasing all the
awesome arts and culture
the Village has to offer.
And the Green School in
Bali made this amazing tour
that showcases
other students what
it's like to get an education
being completely immersed
in nature.
That's right, these students
actually learn outside.
And another school
in Valdemoro, Spain
created a tour of all the
historic sites in Valdemoro
to show other schools what
their community was like.
Now these are just a few
examples of over 300 schools
that have participated
in this program.
And thanks to them, we
now have a ton of feedback
about what it's like to
create your own Expeditions.
And as we were thinking
through that feedback,
it occurred to us that when
it comes to this concept
that Ben mentioned earlier of
transforming abstract concepts
to real ones, perhaps
Expeditions like content
could be useful
outside the classroom.
Let's take the example
of buying a home.
When you're
purchasing a home, you
might consult a whole
bunch of resources
like photos,
brochures, blueprints,
floor plans, in order
to inform your decision.
Now we can imagine
how being immersed
in a virtual tour of
that home would give you
a much better
understanding of what it's
like to actually live there.
That's why we're
super excited today
to announce the launch of Tour
Creator, a web application that
gives anyone the power
to create VR content.
As of today, students,
teachers, businesses, employees,
folks like you and me, we can
all create our own VR tours
and easily share them
anywhere on the web.
When you go to Tour
Creator, you start out
by starting a new tour
or picking up on a draft.
And then you add some basic
metadata, things like a title,
description, category,
and a cover photo.
And then you fill
your tour with scenes.
Scenes are made possible
through the use of 360 photos.
Now if you have your
own 360 photos, awesome.
You can upload them in
just a couple of clicks.
But if you don't, have no fear.
We've integrated directly
with Street View.
So you can take advantage
of the massive library
of 360 photos already
available in Google Maps.
Once you add your
scenes, you add what
we call points of interest.
These are essentially
areas of importance
that you'd like to highlight.
And you can add a little
bit of text information
to inform your viewer.
You can also enrich
these points of interest
with other media like 2D photos.
And in the future, we'll be
adding narration and ambient
audio to help your viewers feel
like they're actually there.
Now when you're done
creating your tour,
you publish it to the web.
You can make it
public for anyone
to see or unlisted so only
those with the link can see it.
And when you publish
it to the web,
you actually publish it to Poly.
If you're not
familiar with Poly,
Poly is Google's
library of 3D content
launched late last year.
Previously, Poly had things
like 3D models, 3D sketches,
and as of today, Poly will
also contain 3D experiences
in the form of tours.
And this is where the true
beauty of this product
comes in.
Because you're publishing
your tour to the web,
all you need to do to
share it is share a URL.
So that means you can view
your tour in 2D on desktop
or on your laptop computer.
You can text a link to your
tour to a friend or colleague.
They can load it on
their mobile device
and simply use Magic
Window to experience it,
or they can tap an
Enter VR button,
put it in a Google
Cardboard, and immediately be
immersed in the tour
that you just created.
Now you may be wondering,
what is this magic?
I thought when it
came to VR, you
have to install a
bunch of apps, get
some really expensive hardware.
Well, this is all made powerful
through a technology called
WebXR that you might have
heard about at the previous I/O
session.
WebXR means that
you can experience
VR content in your browser
using any VR headset.
Another beautiful thing
about publishing these tours
to the web is that you
can easily embed them.
Just go to Poly, click
on a Share button,
and you'll get an
iFrame snippet that you
can put in any blog or website.
And when you think
about it, this
can be truly transformational
for business.
Let's go back to the
example of real estate
that I mentioned earlier.
Imagine a future where
instead of seeing
a series of 2D photos on a real
estate listing online, instead
you saw a virtual
tour of that property
that you were about to buy.
Now you may be
thinking, OK, maybe
businesses will use this thing,
but will they actually use it?
Well, to validate that we were
building the right product,
we actually partnered
with a bunch
of companies across
many verticals
to get their feedback
before we launched.
And we want to share
with you a few examples
of what they've created.
Time Out New York has
been using to Tour Creator
to create tours of having
the best day ever in New York
City, everything
from Central Park
to Lincoln Center to the
New York Public Library.
Imagine It Done,
a company devoted
to helping its clients, like
style icon Lindsay Lane,
organize their lives
and their closets,
has been using Tour Creator
to showcase their expertise.
Now I don't know
about you, but if I
had that many
pairs of shoes, I'd
probably want to see
a tour of how they
were going to organize them.
REA Group, owner of
realestate.com.au, the number
one place for
property in Australia,
has been using Tour
Creator to create
tours to embed in both their
website and their mobile apps
soon.
As they've mentioned
to us, Tour Creator
allows their users to
explore their properties
from wherever they are.
And of course, we've
seen broad applications
for this technology in
enterprise training.
KLM Airlines has been
using Tour Creator
to save lots of money
on training costs
by acclimating their flight
crews to the aircraft
before they even
set foot inside.
Now it's one thing to hear
about these use cases from us.
It's another thing to hear about
them direct from the source.
So let's cut to a
quick video where
we'll share their feedback.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Time Out has always
been about helping
people explore their city.
And Tour Creator
helps us do just that.
It's really going to help
us be able to innovate more
in the digital world and
really create new content.
We get some cool 360
photos, and we just
pop them right
into Tour Creator.
We pull images,
information, fun facts,
things to do in that area,
anything you could really
possibly need to know.
We have some really
cool tours through that.
- We can use Tour
Creator to virtually see
the aircraft, which means that
we can take the people whenever
they want and wherever they
want with virtual reality.
And that saves quite
a lot of money.
- Spectrum Designs
is a full service,
customer-powered
business with a mission,
to provide purposeful work
opportunities and authentic
vocational experiences to
individuals with autism.
Tour Creator has
allowed us to habituate
our staff and our
employees before they even
come in the building.
Before they take one
step over the threshold
into our building,
Tour Creator lets
us show them exactly
what to expect
to become acclimated to
the building, to the noise,
to the machinery.
- The Tour Creator tool
brings everything to life.
Clients feel so
comfortable knowing
what the spaces
are going to look
like by seeing it through
this Tour Creator tool
It's indispensable.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, thank you.
We are super excited to launch
Tour Creator to all of you
today and can't wait
to see all the tours
that you're going to create.
Later this year we'll be
introducing the ability
to add these tours directly
to the Expeditions app,
so stay tuned for that.
And with that, I'll
pass it back off
to Ben for some closing remarks.
[APPLAUSE]
BENJAMIN SCHROM: Thanks, Brit.
So there you have it.
A new powerful AR mode
in Google Expeditions
that packs a universe of places
and things in your pocket
and brings them into your
classroom, onto your desk,
right on top of your textbook.
A wholly online biology degree
from Labster and Daydream
that uses the power
of immersive computing
to make access to
a great education
not reliant on your
geographic proximity to one.
And finally, Tour Creator,
a simple, powerful tool
that makes creating immersive
content accessible to anyone
straight from their web browser.
I want to close on a note
about why this is so important.
I can't really think about
education and technology
without thinking about
this guy, Seymour Papert.
20 years ago, he
observed that it
might be time to reconsider our
fundamental conception of what
a literal person--
I mean-- sorry, not a literal
person, a literate person.
For hundreds of years, the
primary way we've taught things
or learned things in school
was via the written word
or symbols, reading,
writing them.
And while these are
obviously critical skills,
for many people they're really
challenging entry points.
They're about as
abstract as things get.
We have an opportunity
to use technology
to lower these barriers to
make learning richer, less
abstract, to make all
that important reading
and writing that
we do be augmented
with the actual parts of the
world that they refer to.
And we can use photospheres,
sounds, 3D objects,
simulations, all the formats
immersive computing enables,
to give learners
more effective entry
points into complicated
subjects and ideas.
So here's a quote from
one of the teachers who
participated in
Exhibitions AR beta,
and it really resonated with us.
She refers to
something I remember
seeing every day when I was
a teacher over 10 years ago.
Many very, very
smart students, they
might not bring extensive
textual literacy
to their learning
from the get go
for a bunch of different
reasons-- language
barriers, their particular
educational background.
But we traditionally
treat this like it's
a blocker to their learning.
We don't have to.
We all, you all, we
all have an opportunity
to use all these
tools, VR and AR,
to give them a more natural,
more inherently visual entry
point to really important
ideas and learning.
And as this teacher
says, we can help
to level the playing field.
So thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]